we find the world's pickiest eaters
transform the foods they hate with three
incredible dishes
then teach them how to make it that
smells so good
this is the picky eater challenge what's
up y'all i'm chef yadi aka happy healthy
latina aka
the people chef and today we have a
super special victim
named john who got set up by his
girlfriend
tam you know sometimes when you're
living with your boo you find out
certain things like they just will not
eat he's
really really really dramatic he never
liked vegetables
we found out that john hates him some
cauliflower i can't
stand cauliflower was that the rest of
us get cauliflower here and you eating
cauliflower after the name of a
cauliflower that's disgusting why
would you eat some i mean some stuff
like that i'm sorry i love cauliflower
but people have really strong opinions
about it cauliflower can be anything
that you need it to be i think like bob
ross it's like a cute little canvas you
can work with because
it's bland y'all so we got to bring the
flavor to it
let's do it the setup is john and tam
are going to be led in by our producers
come to set thinking they're going to
have a regular meal do you think you can
tell the difference between food that
was made in a restaurant versus
homemade food the goal here is to get
john to do a 180 when it comes to
cauliflower and
actually cook it for himself how do you
feel about foods like like cauliflower
i don't like them
come on down set up time's okay with
chef yachty
he seemed so terrified i was like
i feel like she's always playing tricks
on me man
welcome john and tam what do you think
about your
your digs your new digs i want to burn
it down i definitely
have a big challenge ahead of me i
thought he was going to run off camera
but come on back john
cause we're about to reel you in with
some cauli surprises
this is my intervention tim and i are
here to be
the winds beneath your wings your collie
wings okay
garcon garrick the first thing i need to
do is see how much john
actually hates cauliflower come on
brother brother brother brother come on
we got you a nice raw piece of
cauliflower is there any part of this
that makes you want to like pet it take
a little bite
i think how you just breaking it off so
i see the look of it is something that
you don't like
i've seen it like kind of crumble too so
texture
taste we're moving through some
different culinary techniques right now
so this one is
roasted you're seeing a little bit of a
different texture if you eat just the
burnt part it'll be okay
nope no how does this one look to you it
don't look good it don't look appetizing
it's pickled what if we all went for a
little baby piece
all right okay oh god
what the hell is that this one is
blended cauliflower hell no and we still
haven't gotten one that you would want
to try
let's talk about what you guys do like
to eat vietnamese food
chinese food i love swine i love pig so
you like salty
you like savory you like strong flavors
he likes his you know fast food american
food
i think he needs some help exploring the
other food groups it's just unhealthy
i'm trying to eat healthier that's why
you're trying to get better as a couple
yes ma'am so now i'm about to give it
the people chef chef yachty spin and i'm
about to take you to flavor town
okay see y'all in a few your boy john
is here to give chef yachty a struggle
he does not like the texture the smell
the taste basically everything about the
cauliflower i need to grow a new
vegetable
so i'm about to give john three
different dishes
in three different ways i need to bring
everything i have to this challenge
for the mashed potatoes i'm hoping to
take john straight back into his
childhood classics he said he loves and
he misses american food
and comfort food we're going to
deconstruct the cauliflower i'm going to
need to
break it down so i'm going to bring it
into a food processor take that liquid
out and then i'm going to need to
emulsify it and not let it get too gummy
and to still maintain the integrity of
the mashed potatoes yes
mash has a lot of morals so we want it
not to be a soup not to be a puree we
want it to be a mash those are three
different culinary terms we're showing
cauliflower can be
good old comfort food what are you
smelling what are you seeing
i see mashed potatoes and grits okay
with butter floating right just sitting
in there all right let me see
all right
[Music]
how does it taste it's not bad
it definitely looks and smells a lot
better than it didn't taste
i think it's just a cauliflower man have
the look once you eat a little bit of it
you can tell that it's not
potatoes okay okay but you tasted a
little more than you've ever tasted
i'm gonna taste it oh please
[Music]
oh it's good if i'm gonna get john to
cook with cauliflower
i'm gonna need to really wow him on the
next two dishes
can we have a palate cleanser what is
this
blueberries strawberries honey really
because this is not the only thing that
we're going to taste
sushi rice is its own style of rice it's
a short grain
sticky rice and we're working with
basically a waterlogged
vegetable i'm gonna have to squeeze out
all that extra liquid
and then i'm gonna have to reincorporate
the vinegary sweet flavor that sushi
rice traditionally has so i'm gonna be
making its own little marinade and then
you've got your crispiness from that
taco
and it's going to be all wrapped in
there like a yummy little bit but i
can't overcook it or else it won't hold
its structure
you've got nicely seasoned fish that is
going to have a little bit of spice and
kick to it i really want him to see
the sushi rice and the whiteness of it
really feel the flavor
as he bites into it that it tastes like
sushi oh my god
that looks so good and i gave it the
same treatment as sushi rice oh this one
this one
where's the cauliflower for this one you
put your hands out somebody gonna have a
napkin
god that's good did you taste the
cauliflower at all all i tasted was
delicious deliciousness i'm
finally starting to see john allow
himself to think past the cauliflower
does chef yadi do it for this one i'm a
sucker for sushi man
again call it gang no we ain't gonna say
color game but
arancini is kind of complex my challenge
is really can i make this cauliflower
like
stick but not mushy because a lot of
people think cauliflower is mushy when
you rice it can i get that sear on it by
bringing it into the oven
or by frying it when he has the arancini
ball he's about to get blown back into
another galaxy of flavor
because he is going to experience
creaminess cheesiness
smokiness crunchiness he's not even
going to have time to register whereas
the cauliflower is
everywhere i'm not just putting this
cauliflower in the pressure cooker i'm
putting myself in the pressure cooker
because these balls need to work if they
fall apart in my hands i will cry
i don't want to drop the ball my people
i present to you
arancini balls have you heard about
aaron cheney before
not until now let's try it out
[Music]
how do you like it
you don't get to try it this time go
ahead
five stop doing that i really want to
taste that where do you think the
cauliflower is i think it's in the trash
because the same cauliflower it's the
entire ball
it's only coated in panko the entire
thing is cauliflower seriously
cauliflower
cauliflower oh man is it possible to say
that you like what you've experienced
today
i don't like cauliflower but i like chef
yada's cauliflower
well this all comes with the grand prize
of
you get to cook it oh i gotta cook for
real you're going to learn to cook this
dish and you're going to get in the
kitchen with chef yadi i'm gonna be
there as a coach
but that's gonna be all you boo one
final cheers
cauliflower shooters told ya
he's washing down cauliflower with
cauliflower sorry
the taste testing couldn't have gone
better but for me i'm looking to really
impart
a skill on john and tam that they can do
it for themselves i just don't think
that's gonna happen i mean because
i mean the way he presented it was like
with so many different types of flavors
and
putting her little spin on it i want
john to feel confident
not just in being able to make it but i
want him to be amped about cauliflower
and telling people like you don't even
know
what cauli could be okay john so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to create some flavor by
roasting some garlic we're about to make
a rainbow
we're going to make us rain some oil on
here
okay john it's yo nemesis slash bff
cauliflower we are going to make this
into rice right here
oh you touching the cauliflower john
brave man over here
okay that's about the consistency we're
looking for
oh now the smell is getting too it has a
lot of water inside of it
wrap it up like a cute little baby
squeeze
you can taste the smell that is what you
didn't like about cauliflower so what
we're going to do now is release
the cauliflower we're about to make us
some shiitake bacon just gonna go
butter mushrooms
liquid smoke soy sauce sea salt
all right look at that beautiful crisp
and sear on them so we're gonna get
these mushrooms in the pan
teamwork make the dream work we're gonna
put in some peas
now we're gonna fly some cheese and then
you're gonna incorporate all that by
giving it a nice mix
oh yeah we're just gonna make our
risotto we're going to
put some butter in the pan white wine
some garlic
all that nasty water we took out of our
cauliflower we're going to put this
flavor back in there okay
just get some regular marinara mix it
all
up now let's go ahead and let's put some
cheese on it that's our parmesan
now we want to go in with our mozzarella
smells so good
let's finish it with a little bit of
salt
[Music]
gorgeous amazing so let's mix our
cauliflower rice and our
mushroom and pea mix that is the inside
of our
arancini balls can you believe it's
cauliflower i'm looking at it like it
did i don't even
cauliflower doesn't even exist in this
dish we're gonna put some smoked sweet
paprika
right into our italian bread crumbs
take a nice big ol scoop in there
perfect
tam's gonna hook us up with some egg
wash and then we're gonna get it all up
in our breadcrumbs
remember how you thought they were fried
earlier yes
yes i did actually baked your finding
out sorcery man
[Music]
and then we're going to layer it with
some pesto with a little bit of parmesan
cheese
shiitake bacon and then you're going to
zest it with some lemon
oh wow that looks good
[Music]
it tastes almost like yours almost what
you mean i think it's right on point you
got the crispiness of the crunchiness
honestly this probably might be the only
way that she can never get me to eat
cauliflower i think you did
really really well and i'm very proud of
you i will cheers to that
thank you for being game to try
something you were totally afraid of
thank you for
showing me a a better way a different
path because
i would literally walk out of here today
with the same the same stigma that
cauliflower is disgusting can i be so
bold
as to say that today's picky eater
intervention
actually worked you have to say it
worked it worked it worked
much against the little yachty dance you
do it there
the champ is still here undefeated every
vegetable you send my way i
slay i don't think there's one that
could take me down jeff yachty
[Music]
out
[Music]
you